concussions aren't great
but as long as you have them before
you're 50 it's cool and knoxville is 49.
so we're good
in terms of like
pulling off the movie i feel like i was
the most skeptical i was like
wait we're like 50 what are we doing but
as soon as we shot that first day i was
like oh this is i was just happy
everyone was happy to be there and it
was a hard year obviously for everybody
but like doing this with these guys
and the whole cast and the crew and now
you know we've
been together as a crew for 20 years
i've known him for 30 years and i've
known him for 40 years since i was 12.
yeah we have jeff tremaine that new guy
like this year being together was so fun
and that's what the movie feels like to
me it's like old friends like seriously
old friends being together again and
like old yeah yeah it is it's so funny
like this old
we all know each other's nuances our
vulnerabilities and yeah you know what's
harder this movie was harder for me than
the other ones because i've gotten
fat and my hip is bad
so i can't run away i can't get away
from anybody it's really worked out for
me guys me too hopefully to be on this
side of the pond
you should have laid down and rolled
when you could have got away
i tried i mean you got stun gun at me
and i did that i was just rolling his
backs
just getting hit all differently you're
gonna be dumb you gotta be tough i have
one on me in leaving this movie suppose
this experience for you
like i didn't i we were all unsure going
into it but coming out of it it felt
like all the others it felt as good as
all the others and the friendships that
not only remain but have gotten stronger
over the years uh really mean a lot and
uh for us to still be doing this after
20 years and for it to be as fun as it
is
i think that's special
[Music]
[Music]
you